so Jamie the film is finally being
released what's this process been like
for you yeah i mean that's been a serb
wild like journey you know it's kind of
weird because if we finished filming a
year ago so it's kind of like everyone's
moved on to done of the things and then
we're coming back to it and you know
it's kind of trying to relive it guess
and john did you know it was excited
that finally like a year feels like a
long time to be waiting and you know the
founders a long time for the fans to be
waiting as well you know um so we're
just excited by that were ready to like
offer them what we've made and we feel
really proud of it and we're so excited
for them to see it cool the press and
the fans are really loving the movie um
how does that make you feel yeah it's
great because we had a great time making
it you know i'm dumb i have so much
respect for all the people involved in
making it a samba Dakota in America you
noticed you do everything I you know I
feel that like it deserves to do well
because they're great people and they
work really hard on the film dumb yeah
we're proud of that we thought we've
made a good picture so if people respond
well to it i mean that's great for us
yeah people are very passionate about
this this film yeah well i wasn't
important for you guys to get it right
big just for the reasons that the fans
the fans care about this film so much
like you know on this story in these
books so much that you just wanna you
want to do it for them you know you're
kind of doing it for the funds you know
i know you want to give back to them you
know more so than anything else I've
ever witnessed really like I hired whole
I close to their heart they hold these
characters you know so you just want to
like try to give them what they want
really yeah what was it like working
with dakota johnson and has it been like
sharing this experience with her yea i
meant it was great i mean like from the
moment I met her when I like audition
the first time I was just like I just
need I just felt comfortable with her
you know I just felt like she sort of
got my back and I you know and the
process you know the way things happened
and another actors had he dropped island
so for her was probably quite a strange
thing because he's there really needs to
be a big level of trust with her ever
played Christian grade for her you know
so when you have one after you think
it's going to be
in it he leaves and something you've got
some other guy and you know you've met
another couple of guys and to lead up to
that so it was quite that's been quite
strange for her but she had a little so
well I just she's very following me plea
to the laughs and she says you know I'm
so glad that she was on the journey with
me could have been really difficult if
you didn't get on well with that carrot
you know if I because I didn't get on
well would have been a tricky experience
what are you most excited for audiences
to see in the phone I just like you know
I just the whole film in general because
like it's there's so much going on in
this film you know it's not just about
the sex you know it's an erotic film of
course but it's also very much like a
love story and we just want to get that
across you know we want people to be
like excited by it stimulated by it but
like also like just to really feel that
that's very core is in love story so I'm
hoping that people take that from it and
what made Sam taylor-johnson the perfect
director for this film she just got so
much like style grace she's so
sophisticated I think it neat really a
film like this needed to be and like
classy hands you know and someone who
understands higher to make something
without you know just make something
that that like a great picture beyond
everything else that comes of it and
that's always say this about Sam sure
disability just to make it feel like
we're just making a picture just make it
that you're like any other picture and
to block out all of the the craziness
and the anticipation and samis amazing
ability to do that you know and um and
then I think she'd done before it's just
done with it sir like an artistic I am
so much class so when I was you know I
was one of the main reasons I got
excited about this in the first place of
self
you